yeah your life is so insane you should
write a book since when did you learn
how to read I do know how to read though
yeah you know how to read a
menu this
[Music]
guy I he's right I mean I could lose
some weight Kevin in Sumo culture you'd
be considered a promising up andc
Comer
who did this to you where is
he
what no it's not it's
nothing it's hot in here
yeah
thanks you don't need to stay here I
know
is your PMSing pretty bad
huh Three Amigos warms my heart hey what
do you say when I get back from our
honeymoon the three of us have a
conference room meeting just for
fun what is that meaningful look you
know what maybe we should
talk hey come here you guys need to see
this is it you're probably sitting there
wondering what will be your mark what
will you be known
for it might surprise you to learn I
finally feel ready athlete is growing
athlete and Jim can jump back in without
skipping a beat we'll come back to visit
but I think it's time for us to
officially no don't say it you're fired
you're both fired wa come on don't end
on a bad note don't be an idiot it's for
the severance the best that I can do is
one month for year you've been here
that's the
max thanks
Dwight hey and if you're ever an Austin
right for what the art the music the
incredible night life no thank you but
if you're ever in the area you'll always
have a place to stay in my
barn there it
is this office administrator thing I
don't want
to what fail I don't want to fail again
you didn't didn't fail that's what you
said about art school and that's what
you said about sales and you didn't fail
those things
either
well I'm not an artist and I'm not a
Salesman so what would you call it hey
heyy
hey I wasn't
here what I wasn't here it's a pretty
common say you may want to log it away
for future use well thanks yeah
hello hello you're breaking the law
impossible I love the law read article
19 there are certain standards that you
have to maintain the building at and
that includes comfortable temperatures
and adequate lighting it also means no
more cutting the tampons in two and no
more tampering with the toilet paper you
see I've underestimated you and I didn't
think that was possible
Nate reply the paper I I don't think it
goes that way reply
it they say the best vampires don't
bleed their victims dry but give them
the strength so that they can bounce
back only to be fed on again I spared
Pam that I might Feast off of her
profits for years to come I let Pam
win I was not motivated by
compassion I have no
compassion make sure you got
that not more motivated by
compassion go to my house get my iPad I
think it's on the kitchen table do not
touch anything
else
what I couldn't find your
iPod just give me a couple
days get out of your
hair with the python but the Rattler's
so scary no please I find the rattle
soothing puts me to sleep I think Bob's
going to cheat on me with his new
secretary not so funny when I say it out
loud it it's so
silly oh man is that a prism Duro
sport you've seen one of these yeah
they're like an iPod only they're better
cuz they're chunkier and more solid Roy
gave it to me for Christmas I'm trying
to figure out how to put songs on it oh
no no no don't go
there I know this Russian website where
you can download songs for 2 cents a
piece really yeah I'll write down the
address for you only the only thing is
is that all the songs are in
Russian
kidding
oh why would they all
be okay see you later
pan these covers are totally
indestructible really yeah throw it I
promise it won't break check
it oh no it's broken what no it's fine I
told you it wouldn't break you could
throw it all day long that is so cool
thanks
Dwight let me help you Dwight come
on get up get the best yeah just keep
them away it smells like chicken soup I
know I have to go to the hospital I know
where are we going I just want to say
goodbye okay I'll be back I mean yes I
know but it's going to be different why
it's just hard to explain oh Pam you're
adorable oh my
goodness come here oh Huggy hug this is
a one time thing you know that right wow
this is it all right this is where the
magic happens nice very nice one of you
can have the sofa and one of you can
have the Flo I got the sofa I got sofa
Dwight I've got the sofa I'm the boss I
got floor in case anybody needs to go to
the bathroom in the middle of the night
I don't want to get my head stepped on
do you want me to sing you a song my
mother used to sing me when we were sick
[Music]
no leave him alone it's a lullabi felt
like I almost lost her and and nothing
is worth that boy I tell you Jim a lot
of guys in my circle they wouldn't even
change their golf schedule to shore up
their marriage let alone their
professional
goals dude there is no way that Jim is
just back here to hang out with
Pam you did not just say that
you don't know Pam she is really cool
all I'm saying is forget about my chair
he wants the manager's chair I thought
you wanted that job yeah I did but I
made too many mistakes it's out of my
reach now besides I think Jim would be a
fine
manager I'd be happy to see Jim as
manager so do you want to see it or not
I don't know I feel like Friday night
crowds oh my God you're like agoraphobic
agoraphobic yeah really yeah you would
rather sit on your couch and watch a
Philly game than go out to a movie with
your awesome girlfriend absolutely
correct later Jem Kev have a good
weekend man bye okay so this is what's
going to happen you're going to suck it
up here we go and we're going to go to
dinner okay and then we're going to go
to the movie sounds good hey
helper hey
r r
go Pam please call
security every day for 8 years I have
brought pepper spray into this office to
protect myself and my fellow employees
and every day for 8 years people have
laughed at me well who's Laughing
Now D myth and this is Pam has Michael
checked in oh hey Dwight I asked you a
question no he hasn't goodbye no wait um
hey while you're out could you pick up
some paper towels and chocolate syrup we
have ice cream so I thought we could Dam
this isn't a shopping trip this is a
Manhunt Rescue Mission okay I just when
you're done or anytime it's convenient I
just thought since you're out Dam I'm
obviously going to get that stuff for
you so just shut up okay well it wasn't
OB
[Music]
did you have fun at Benny hana's no it
was awful you couldn't hear
[Applause]
anything I've had the worst day
[Music]
here
baby